voilà c'est donc dans cet état d'esprit
que nous avons invité le chanteur alain
bashung puisque plus connus pour un
certain nombre de titres que pour sa
participation à des manifestations pas
de politique partisane mais de politique
générale vous allez participer vendredi
un gala avec d'autres artistes contre
l'acteur contre la torture au zénith
pour amnesty international vous avez
regardé avec nous ce journal depuis son
début est ce que vous vous sentez
concerné par tout ces problèmes comme
ceux de manille par exemple est évident
il est plus facile pour un français
d'être sympathisants pour ce mouvement
c'est plus difficile au chili où on est
on sait ce dont il faut profiter de
cette liberté pour faire connaître ce
mouvement et faire reculer les limites
de tout ce qui concerne la torture la
censure ou les emprisonnements pour des
raisons d'opinion donc il n'est pas trop
tard pour le faire et on le fait donc le
vendredi 18 avec plein d'autres
camarades
mais je peux vous en citer quelques uns
à l'orias jane birkin qui va arriver
qui va chanter pour la première fois sur
scène pierre desproges viande y aura une
animation avec angela gréco jean guidoni
à la préfinale la promenade gilbert
laffaille mabéa alexandre révérence à
faux traction avant trust and down town
zéro de conduite tout cas j'en oublie
donc voilà pour la la mission que vous
avez rempli vis-à-vis d'amnesty
international alain vachon vous
appartenez à la jeune génération de la
chanson française vous n'avez pas connu
une certaine norme deux périodes dans ce
pays où les libertés ont été réprimées
ce que vous vous sentez concerné par le
combat des pour les libertés comme
chanteur comme artiste ça se passe à des
degrés divers en europe ou en france
c'est à dire c'est peut-être plus
hypocrite donc faut faire très attention
il faut pas seulement se dire que ça se
passe ailleurs et que on peut commenter
de temps en temps les images à la
télévision
ça peut les temps changent
en ce moment donc des choses peuvent
arriver très rapidement d'une manière
insidieuse
donc il faut essayer si on veut penser
un petit peu assoiffés c'est penser un
peu aux autres et je crois que c'est le
meilleur moyen de penser à soi
est-ce que parmi parmi vos amis ce
qu'ils chantent de la jeune génération
comme vous en ce sens concernée par le
statut de l'artiste dans la cité ce que
l'on se dit comme certaines certains
chanteurs qui vous ont précédés moi je
connais la chanson je fais pas de
politique
ou est ce que on a une autre manière
d'aborder les choses aujourd'hui on
s'est dit je suis plus même si ça se
jette lui aussi citoyen ça se passe
d'une manière plus épidermique peut-être
il ya eu de mouvement punk par exemple
qui a été très important qui est qui qui
ne voulait rien expliqué en fait mais
qui voulait simplement faire exploser
les choses plus ou moins traditionnels
etc comme un bouton qui pousse sur la
figure c'est exactement ça je sais
combien des gens il ya pas mal de gens
qui en parlent d'une manière beaucoup
plus plus en détail ou plus
intelligemment que certains artistes
pourraient le faire on n'est pas là pour
pour parler politique vraiment mais on a
une sensibilité de demont dylan l'a fait
à une époque malheureusement ça ça fait
reculer peut-être des choses mais il
faut pas se dire que ça suffit donc
c'est pas parce qu'on va chanter le 18
amnesty que ça que ça va forcément
bouleverser tout mais il faut se dire
que la moindre petite lettre reçue ou
plus le mouvement va grandir va prendre
de l'expansion et et mieux ce sera alors
il ya c'est cette année le petit le
petit détail enfin jeunes sur la
contribution est très faible il faut
penser que c'est utile c'est votre part
d'utopie et de militantisme et une
certaine manière mais je
j'ai eu la preuve que l'utopie pouvait
apporter quelque chose donc je suis
utopiste
bien sûr vous avez raison de l'être il
ya cet aspect des choses où on participe
à un gala organisé par une association
qui fait de la politique au sens large
du terme
et puis il ya aussi comme vous le disiez
des chansons qui exprime un certain
combat c'était par exemple les pins coup
les beatniks vous vous le faites aussi
dans vos chansons ça va essayer de le
faire
ça m'est arrivé oui pour réveiller les
gens c'est à dire qu'une espèce de
tradition comme ça il m'est arrivé de
faire des télévisions qui était qui ont
coupé la france en deux parce que
c'était c'était pas pour scandalisé
c'était uniquement pour éveiller et je
crois que les artistes ont plutôt
intérêt à faire ça puisque dans l'autre
côté des gens plus spécialisés le font
d'une manière tout à fait normal c'est à
nous de lever des voiles d'une autre
manière avec nos moyens nous merci à la
mâchoire ne vous a pas écouté chanter
vous étiez là pour nous parler de votre
participation à ce gala d'amnesty
international les artistes contre la
torture vendredi le 18 mai à 20h merci
beaucoup d'être venu en 2010 nous allons
continuer